and now sue mning to the meat of the
program let's play tonight's hashtagwars
tonight's very cool to have Jeff here
wilcos fantastic van you should see them
live if you get the chance to comedians
not every song can be a hit which is why
tonight's hashtag is one word off songs
examples might be good out of my car get
in to my car uh I'm gonna put 60 seconds
on the clock and begin
Jen Kirkman um I'm trying to break your
fart come on boys
so willful songs working look at out
working title Dave Koechner ah this
one's semi-autobiographical started as a
bottom all right points chef Feenie gu
bloody al Qaeda yeah come on Eileen yes
huh I'm just changing the ted's really
does yeah Jen nothing compares to Jews
all right boys Dave Koechner
hey hit my baby one more time all right
points chef sweetie sweet home
Williamsburg yes boys chef devil went
down to Hooters yes points points also
looking for a soul to steal Janet smells
like teen scrotum
trusty dude looks like a dude all right
boy perfect beautiful